[Musik]
wir werden sowieso zu sehen
das ist schon heftig jetzt kommen die
leute heute wieder mit einem spezial
wieder einen besonderen gast neben mir
loren und wie ihr im titel gesehen habt
leute ist die schauspielerin bei kras
schule der kontakt zustande gekommen
leute das nur reden und freunde von
meiner freundin ist und ja wir haben
schon darüber geredet wie auch - für
einmal zusammen reaction machen du warst
dabei übrigens auch noch intakt ist und
wahrscheinlich verengt checkt das hat
mir gefallen und ich würde sagen wir
haben zufolge rausgesucht die mehr oder
weniger exemplarisch so kannst du mit
deiner erfahrung damit zeigt und wir
wirklich sagen schön dass mal einer
kommt mir bekannt vor
ok taste walter camper ist das ganze
video das dreht sich rund um eine schuld
trifft wahrscheinlich genau ein
wettkampf gegen andere schule wettkampf
gegen eine andere schule und wir müssen
irgendwie in der wildnis überleben und
zu diesem zweck hast du wie ich hier
auch sehr dich auch der umgebung
angepasst
du wirst sie undercover und ja das ist
ein ganz normaler schulalltag einfach
mal kurz mäßig in der wildnis überleben
[Musik]
jetzt immer wie wie ist das jetzt wie
ist dass das zu drehen ist es ein
nächstes allgemein für dich so wir haben
ja also ich als youtube kanal und kann
keine ahnung
hier ist das also bei der serie
mitspielen das sage ich ganz nicht oder
ja ja es macht spaß und ist auch hier
fallen die ganze schulzeit in des lebens
doch wie weit theorie war eher kalt und
er für mich nicht so geil weil ich
joja ja stimmt so im wald wecken und so
ist und ist so ein thema
die leute müssen jetzt mal wir haben
jetzt nämlich auch eine besondere frage
zu stellen so etwas sein wie erzähle wie
ist das ganze bei dir entstanden
überhaupt wie kamst du da hin zur schule
ja ich habe eine anfrage bekommen ob
sich bekennt er zum casting zu kommen
und dann war ich glaube eine woche
später beim casting und ich glaube
knappen monat später ein anruf bekommen
ist nicht programmiert zu spielen weil
es dann erst dann erste schauspiel
sachen ich war vorher schon bei anderen
serien dabei also aber jetzt nicht so
groß ist und dann nur so kleine rollen
immer wieder was schon beihilfen aber
guck mal die sprüche zum beispiel die
das ist ja so ein bisschen aufruf wie
schon oder so also sag mal so auch aber
aber so bist du so lost hyde ist auch so
dazu aber das ist echt krass so drüber
nachdenkt so krass schule ist ja auch so
eine serie die so riecht viele junge
leute heute so suchten in deutschland
also die schauen dass und das ist für
diese das muss man sich vor augen hält
auch alle die jetzt so aus dem 12 13 14
das sind so die sache die diese komplett
verfolgen und somit die die groß werden
wie wie ist es da dass somit zu spielen
also bist du der kontakt auch mit mit
fans
ja sonst natürlich werden auch oft viele
fans am set gehabt und ja die feier das
aussicht ich denke dass realität alles
da muss ein bisschen die realität wieder
wegnehmen weil wir sind ja auch eigene
menschen wir sind jetzt nicht ich bin ja
nicht ich bin drehen sagt lorenz rolle
das ist ja nicht so dass habe ich auch
schon von einer freien gehört heute dass
zuschauer von der serie die das auch
volk feiern dich mit deinem serie namen
ansprechen
ja ist das letzte was wir werden am set
meist dicht akin genannt deswegen höre
ich mittlerweile auch auf diesen namen
ja echt du wirst auch von den kollegen
am set mit einem jahr das passiert schon
mal man spielte den ganzen tag so
mussten personen die ganze zeit bei
rollen lag ansprechen und wenn man dann
privat unterwegs ist da passiert das
also geht es aber krass alter in dieser
ersten folge ist dann ja nicht mehr so
viel passiert deswegen spring jetzt
weiter heute werden nur zweite folge
herausgesucht und die ist deutlich
krasser wir haben einen ersten drehtage
wir haben noch ein zweites video leute
das ist ein bisschen exquisiter sagen
wir es mal als das erste
weil das ist auch also den bei kasse ist
ja auch schon teilweise bisschen
freizügiger so diese durchaus kann man
schon sagen na schauen wir mal ein
heißer flirt rein
ich war nicht ganz so ganz anderer
stelle im video
aber kann man hier einfach es ist eine
leere
hier ist ein lehrer passt am sterben
alles was er das heute geht also tod
vorgetäuscht
sie küsst zu retten ist einfach ein du
meinst dass bei einer deiner deiner
ersten drehtage gewesen
erste drei wochen aber ist es okay ist
das nachsehen in köln alle die in köln
wohnen werden es kennen alle anderen
wahrscheinlich nicht wie wahr wie war
das eigentlich also dass jetzt eine
deiner ersten drei wochen und kriegst du
das dann vorher schon mitgeteilt dass
das jetzt noch ein bisschen freizügigere
szene ist oder so sehen natürlich was
gedreht wird oder ob der text und passt
dann können wir natürlich auch sagen
passt uns nicht gehört habe dass bitte
um aber kommt eigentlich vor und dann
kriegst einen tag vorher wie gesagt am
nächsten tag der mir die und ich sehen
und dann ist sie zum beispiel dabei war
es am nächsten tag richtig sehen ob sie
mit magie zusammen ok und egal welcher
art funktion dabei liebesszenen oder was
auch immer
mein liebstes steht natürlich auch dann
das drehbuch wollen das machen kann was
da passieren können gerade eben mit
jaqueline im wasser war schon ziemlich
nah ist ich meine im wasser hält sich
auch endlich mal die klappe und nicht so
viel dass das ist mal wieder in der
serie sollte sich nicht eigentlich so
eine seite ich eigentlich ein liebespaar
was so ein bisschen so ich habe ja
gerade erst kennengelernt
du bist du okay okay okay und dieser
kann sie jetzt so am besten sucht läuft
es läuft zum ersten mal wichtiger player
oder er hat schon ist der fall also
jetzt in der serie man also echt nicht
aber sag mal sag mal wie ist es so das
läuft ja auch im fernsehen wird ja auch
von dem recht großen publikum im
fernsehen ausgestrahlt hast du dann als
ich das erste mal so eine szene von
derart gemacht hat als er soll darauf
schon dass es im bikini oder soweit war
das für dich irgendwie irgendwas robert
und nach gedacht hast oder das ist
einfach ganz normal so ist kein problem
schafft erst mal gemacht meine
allerersten szene die ich habe am ersten
drehtag war auch komplett in unterwäsche
jungen leute nicht am ersten drehtag
training machen wir irgendwann die tage
und dann habe ich wieder kommen die
teams durch name die abends spät noch
gedreht
das ist so krank leute wirklich dass der
erste drehtag war einfach eine szene wo
du wirklich seine unterwäsche so quasi
rumgemacht hass und auch das war mit
nach wieder auch so und du sagst du auch
nicht hingestellt wurden videos
einbinden
aber das ist krass
eigentlich brauchen mal kurz ein
screenshot davon muss manchmal muss man
nicht machen so leute das ist einfach
mal sinnbildlich und es geht noch weiter
krass wie war das denn das damit dass am
ersten drehtag zuzudrehen schon hätte
schon crazy oder ich hab ich ein
bisschen angst genommen
ja krass und dann im nachhinein war es
wahrscheinlich gar nicht so schlimm wie
man sie das vorgebracht hatte
also fand ich es macht ja das ist das
spiel schnell machen dass man so ein
bisschen so ein gedanke sich darauf
einstellen und er wollte dir was über
franks erzählt wir haben erste break
master an der schule die typen leute
kennt alle typen wollen immer was von
trinks erzählen männer denken wir nur an
franks und frauen wollen hat auch über
emotionale sachen reden über ihn welche
frauen für die zum beispiel sexy finde
sagt filme gucke ich eigentlich meisten
zombie filme und nicht so viele schöne
frauen dabei aber auch was ich von
abtrocknen und die gelegenheit schöne
frauen abtrocknen
doch doch das ist tatsächlich eine der
größten priorität nicht in meinem leben
gesetzt haben jeder mensch hat alle
seine ziele im leben haus familie frau
kinder wie auch immer aber das problem
ist wenn du eine frau hast kannst du nur
eine frau abtrocknen dass das problem
frau genau mein ziel ist hat mehrere
frauen abzutrocknen einfach noch einfach
massa war einfach der abtrocknen
[Gelächter]
perfektes von seinem element
einfach frauen abtrocknen das klingt
einfach so absurd so was ist dein ziel
lebens einfach trocken einfach scheiße
karriere ist auch nicht so wichtig genau
wovon machen den karriere um frauen
abtrocknen zu können am ende das ist
eigentlich das größere ziel leute sowie
zeugen alle anderen jungs möchte jetzt
verraten aber so ist es einfach wir
erstens sowieso zu sehen
das ist schon heftig dass wir auch mit
was für mich richtig cool weil aber das
kenne ich auch ich habe es auch bei
meinen eigenen video so dass ich die
nicht so nicht unbedingt gern noch mal
anschauen
ja genau ja weil man sich immer so noch
kleinigkeiten die man anders machen will
was man machen will
ja das ist das natürlich auch noch mal
so ein thema aber krass das ist schon
heftig erzieher wie ist das eigentlich
wenn du jetzt so alan set kommt hier
erster der oder einer der ersten tage
und hier wird sie gesagt okay das ist
jetzt ein dreh partner ihr müsst so ein
kurs für den film machen ist dann ist
das etwas was am anfang schwer fällt
ich habe mich am anfang mit magie jetzt
auch zusammen hingesetzt haben gerade so
wie machen wir das am ende gleich und
wir haben nicht geübt und dann einfach
so wir machen so wie es kommt und dann
ist gut also geübt wurde quasi heißen
dass man ohne kamera sie haben mal küste
um das zu handeln
das ist vorbild das kann man sich ja
krass aber und wie fühlst du es an es
ist wahrscheinlich auch weil
normalerweise ich hätte jetzt noch so
viele fragen leute noch andere videos
immer zusammen anschauen könnte aber so
ein video kann leider auch nicht ewig
lang sein
deswegen lorin vielen dank dass du mit
gemacht hast wir können wir schauen ob
wir den kommentaren vielleicht wie vor
fragen einfach nur was auch mal falls
ich etwas passiert schreibt und in die
kommentare ein check wie gesagt loren
hat ist in der beschreibung verlinkt der
erste link leute und ja für die
vollstreckung caroline ist noch nicht
heraus macht's gut